[Música]
alguna vez se pusieron a pensar cuántas
imágenes vemos por día
y si nos ponemos a pensar un poquito más
allá cuántas vemos por mes
quizá podemos pensar cuántas imágenes
vemos
al año
cuentas son cientos de miles millones
y las vemos en las tablets en los
celulares en las redes que instagram que
facebook en la calle en los carteles
estamos todo el tiempo consumiendo
imágenes
hace 200 años que se inventó la
fotografía y nunca antes como en este
tiempo podemos tener el bombardeo de
imágenes que tenemos permanentemente
ahora la pregunta de vengo a hacerles es
hay algunas de esas imágenes que vemos
durante el año que se conecte con
nuestro ser
hay alguna imagen que ustedes pueden
recordar para el resto de su vida
bueno como lulú me presento también soy
diego soy fotógrafo y saben que pienso
en esta imagen reveladora acá todos los
días de mi vida
pero no les miento en este millón de
imágenes siempre pienso cómo tener esa
imagen reveladora que se conecte con lo
que soy
y esta pregunta que me hago se me viene
a la cabeza con muchísima más fuerza
cuando alguien compra un cuadro mí se lo
lleva a su casa y se lo lleva para
colgarlo en la pared y verlos todos los
días
yo digo que vio esa persona
que buscaba esa persona o lo que para mí
es muchísimo más fuerte es que encontró
esa persona en esa imagen
hay un sentimiento similar que me pasa
habitualmente cuando cuando ven a charlo
cuando estoy en una muestra o en una
galería se me acerca a gente y me hace
muchas de estas preguntas
esperando la respuesta es diego cómo se
hace para hacer el fotógrafo
imagínense yo quisiera tener una
respuesta contundente académica perfecto
impecable prolija y lo único que atinó
decir siempre es una fotografía cómo
vives
imagínense la cara de la pobre persona
que venía a buscar un tipo una hoja de
ruta un consejo este la tiene clara
tiene la vaca atada en vas a ver como
y lo único que siempre digo es una
fotografía cómo vive
entonces empiezo a pensar
que uno es en el fondo las decisiones
que vas tomando a lo largo de toda la
vida
en definitiva empiezo a pensar
que uno ve lo que es
hay un gran filósofo que dice las cosas
no son como son sino son como la vemos
1 en definitiva al final del día va a
sacar la foto que es como persona
si me pongo a hacer un poco de memoria a
lo largo de mis años
pienso muy chiquito cuál es esa imagen
que a mí me impactó de chico cuál es
y recuerdo un enorme tanque australiano
de más de 20 metros de diámetro que era
la pileta de la quinta de mi abuelo
impresionante
para mí era el mar
para mí era más grande que el mar
y en esa pileta jugaba mi hermano
fernando mi abuelo mis padres mis primos
todos estaban ahí y yo contemplaba
estaba daniel el hijo de tití manu era
los caseros de la quinta
y era realmente un lugar mágico donde en
el parque estaba lleno de higueras
había un galpón gigante con lleno de
objetos rarísimos
muy raros cosas que yo por supuesto el
único que hacían a mirar formas ahí
adentro
una terrible cancha de fútbol
abajo de un gigantesco eucalipto
racing boca-river mucho a racing
y yo contemplaba
porque hasta los 6 años de mi vida yo
tuve una vida de muchísima quietud
yo nací con una tetralogía de fallot una
enfermedad cardio digamos una
cardiopatía congénita que uno viene de
fábrica con eso es un agujero entre el
tabique ventricular entre otras cosas se
llama tetera pues tiene cuatro problemas
y lo que era un chico cianótico un chico
azul
un blue boy esto lo que implicaba es que
el corazón no podía oxigenar la sangre
que mi cuerpo necesitaba y por ende me
ahogaba
y tengo recuerdos serios de lo que me
copé los de lo que me costaba respirar y
tengo recuerdos serios de que caminaba
por la calle aún para casi y cuando a
veces mamá me bajaba para caminar unos
metros yo me ponía en cuclillas para
poder recuperar el oxígeno que
necesitaba también mamá llevaba una
jeringa en la cartera que lo que hacía
era el hago un fusible un seguro por si
llegaba a entrar en alguna crisis
me llevaban al borde de ese mar
y yo lo único que hacía
ir a contemplar
estaba sin movimiento básicamente pero
por suerte a los 6 años y gracias a los
milagros de la medicina llegó la
operación reparadora
unos genios
el amor de mis viejos y un montón de
cosas hicieron que la vida cambiará para
siempre
durante esa operación que duró más de
siete horas tuve tres paros cardíacos
por reacción a la anestesia lo que
implicó que estuve
más de tres veces desconectado
físicamente
pero volví
y gracias a dios' sobrevivir y acá estoy
50 y pico de años después caminando en
la montaña a 2000 metros de altura con
mochilas que pesan más de 20 y pico de
kilos
cámaras de placas foto metros
y tengo que dar reconocer que esos
primeros 67 años de mi vida de quietud
de ahogo de contemplación son los que me
hicieron el fotógrafo que soy hoy
tengo que reconocer que lo que fue esa
etapa donde mis padres y mi hermano y
mis primos se ocuparon de mí
hicieron que sea la persona que yo soy
hoy y desde esa persona yo hoy
fotografía
contemplar
implica mirar desde el corazón yo no
tengo mucha autoridad para hablar de
esto pero realmente es conectarse con lo
más profundo que tenemos adentro con mis
alumnos siempre hablamos del ser
y de todas estas cosas que nos pasan y
acá se llega a un montón de gente con
angustia con alegrías con éxtasis vienen
de lejos algunos vienen de cerca otras
profesiones
y todos sabemos que la fotografía para
nosotros en el fondo es una terapia es
una forma de conectarnos con lo que
somos
yo durante 8 años me senté frente a este
viejo a ryan está acá cerquita
y lo único que hacía era preguntarle
cómo fotografiarlo
era tan fuerte lo que sentía frente a él
que sentía que todo lo que yo podía
hacer con la cámara no le hacía justicia
ocho años después una tarde casi de
noche con muy poca luz me llegó la
respuesta
y ahí volví a casa y le dije a gaby baby
tenemos que hacer esta foto la vi y la
entiendo vamos nos pusimos a trabajar
hoy está colgada en el living de mi casa
y la miro todos los días
y esa es la foto que quise llevar a mi
casa para ver todos los días y saben lo
que siento que él es mi abuelo con mi
hermano y todos mis primos que de alguna
manera me están mirando es una
fotografía que hice ahora mucho tiempo
después
en otro formato y en blanco y negro
oscar wilde dice que
la magia del mundo es está en lo visible
y no en lo invisible
en un paisaje y un montón de cosas que
uno puede ver pero uno tiene que hacer
lo que tiene que hacer es buscar qué es
esa porción del paisaje que te está
gritando y te está diciendo alguna era
acá está y eso es lo que se conecta con
lo más profundo vos crees que es un
proceso de pensamiento profundo es un
pensamiento es un proceso de
sentimientos
la mirada tiene que estar muy entrenada
para ver la belleza
para mí la belleza es sanadora
krishnamurti decía
que no existe la verdad
sin el amor y sin la belleza
hay otro autor muy importante que dice
que la belleza no es de quien la posee
sino de quién puede contemplarla
la belleza puede estar reflejada en un
montón de cosas
y los parámetros de la belleza no son
iguales para cualquiera no es lo mismo
el que fotografía el pelo de una mujer
en una propaganda o el que quiere
fotografiar el amor de su familia
reflejada en la superficie de un
estanque
cada vez que me meto abajo de esa tela
me pica la panza de la misma manera que
me picaba al borde de la pileta
siento exactamente lo mismo
y cuando en ese recuadro aparece una
foto o voy a ser más preciso cuando en
ese recuadro sucede una foto
esa es la imagen que yo personalmente me
llego al cuarto oscuro
y es ahí en el cuarto oscuro
donde encuentro todas las respuestas
donde encuentro lo visible y lo
verdadero
es ahí en el cuarto oscuro
donde todo se empieza a revelar en la
oscuridad y en el silencio encuentro la
verdad
y una vez que ahí se revela
lo más importante es que se revela para
siempre
y lo mágico es que se revela dentro de
nuestro muchas gracias
[Aplausos]